joanna what's going on how can i help my
husband and i have been married for six
years about three and a half years ago
he confessed to me that he has been
a cocaine addict and an alcoholic since
he was 13 years old
and ever since then we've been
struggling with this
um like trying to get him free i guess
from addiction
so i was calling to see your opinion on
when is it
time to decide if he needs to go to
rehab
there's a lot there can i ask you a
couple of questions that i'm just
curious
about okay for sure um
i've been very close to folks who have
struggled with cocaine have been very
close to folks who have struggled with
alcohol i've been very close with folks
and worked with
countless numbers of folks young people
um through various forms of addiction
how do you be married to somebody for
six years and not know they're a cocaine
addict and an alcoholic
okay well it was two and a half years
but for sure
like i guess it's because i
i i have never been around it myself
ever i you were super around it a lot
you just didn't know you didn't know
that's what that was
and i saw i i mean looking back i'm like
oh yeah it was pretty much i just
you know i would see him well now it's
like okay
you were kind of like detoxing and you
were crazy but i just didn't
i just let him you know do whatever like
he would be angry and all this stuff but
i was like oh he's just an angry person
who cares
and i just kind of turned a blind eye to
it really
and he never used in front of you once
in that many years
no no definitely not no how old are you
i'm uh 32 32 so
was that for 15 years he's been a coke
addict
yes yeah are you sure that's what that
is
i was gonna say have you ever been
around a coke addict who's been a coke
addict for a decade
but you just said no you haven't
it's really
it's hard to be functional at this point
does he go to work every day
he works his brains out yeah that's
the deal he's a very functioning
cocaine alcoholic okay like
super uh he started his own business
was successful with it with a partner i
mean
so yeah he was very successful that's i
think why i just kind of didn't
think about it so yeah the dirty secret
about cocaine is that it works
real good it works real good you will
outwork people you will get a lot
done you will be a rock star in the way
we've set up society
and then everything around you falls
apart right
it just melts underneath you so what
what brought about him telling you
um that he had a problem
i think he at the time uh he just
he was just tired of it he just didn't
want it anymore and i think also
what happened was his childhood was
absolutely horrible
sure we've we confronted his parents
about it and
actually cut them out of our lives
because they were that bad
and then it was six months after that
that he told me
so i feel like it was because he was
dealing with that and he finally was
like
if i dealt with that and i'm throwing
off pretty much like the shackles of my
childhood
i need to deal with this like this is my
crutch and that is why i had the crutch
in the first place
yeah so i um
i'm going to take a different tack than
you probably were thinking um
okay i'm heartbroken for your husband
because i know that's exhausting
and i know that um i don't say that
lightly cocaine works man it helps numb
stuff out it helps you get crap done
it helps you um get up and get to where
you need to be and get stuff done and
get stuff done
it's a connection issue right and it
covers up for
a number of cracked and fractured and
broken
and hurting relationships um
and yeah it works until it doesn't and
when it doesn't it takes down
everyone around you right and so
um i'm just trying to put myself in his
head that
man once i confront my parents once i go
through that gauntlet then this is just
gonna
i'm gonna be free of this and then he
tries month one and month two and month
three and then all of a sudden it gets
real scary because you can't stop right
and um so here's here's three things
i'm just thinking here's three things
you gotta
rattle around in your head okay tell me
if i'm on the mark here
number one harsh reality is someone you
love is hurting real bad is that right
yes okay and they're hurting real bad
and they're a drug addict
is that right yes okay number two
you were lied to for a long time by
somebody you love
is that hurt there also yes yeah
okay and then the third hurt we often
don't think about
is there a part of you that can't fathom
this is the same question i asked you
right when when at the beginning of this
call how in the world you missed this
yes uh yeah i will see that
i was a single mother um when we got
married and i think that what it was was
i
i had struggled so long as a single mom
i was single mom for five years
and then i was like it's not like i was
looking for men but when i found him i
was like oh my god this is the one blah
blah
yeah then it was like my battles over
and i so it was just like
and you'll put up with anything just for
that security right yeah
yeah yeah exactly so i think that's what
was going on
is he at a place where he wants to go to
rehab
yes okay and actually it's a little
funny that i
i was kind of at a moment of despair um
and i sat down at the
computer and i went to your website and
i like typed in this message like my
husband is a cocaine addict thing and um
when is it time to decide to go to rehab
and i didn't send it i was just in
despair and i was like
whatever john delaney doesn't want to
hear this and my husband
saw it like hours later and he sent it
for me
oh wow like he does want answers
okay like he wants something okay
so um the
man my head was going in a totally
different direction um
so i'm gonna tell you i think i love
your husband and i'm proud of him
i'm not proud of him for lying to you
i'm not proud of him for
deceiving those who love and care for
him i'm not
um but my heart's broken for him and so
i'm not gonna
beat him up if he was here i would hug
him and i'd hug him real real hard
okay when it's time to go to rehab is
when he
is ready to go and
until he's ready to go ultimatums
forcing if you don't do this what you're
doing is your weaponizing relationship
your weaponizing connection which is the
one
thing that continues this drug use over
and over and over and over again
right yeah and so it's going to sound
like i'm splitting hairs here but what
you have to do
is you've got to develop strong
boundaries
not walls not build walls right so
you're not building a wall to keep him
from you you are building boundaries to
keep you safe
and sometimes that boundary means you
got to go you got to get out of this
home that we've shared
sometimes boundaries mean no all the
time boundaries mean
you cannot have cocaine around my
children
period right yes so there's those type
of boundaries
are you physically and psychologically
safe
are you safe in your home environment
does he love you that way
yes okay so no harm no
scary nights no at the end of a four day
bender
and you know that that pinwheel eye i'm
talking about right when it is just all
bloodshot pinwheels
and he can steer a hole through you um
and he's checking the
the peephole to the curtains to the
peephole back to the curtains because he
hasn't slept in 72 hours
you're safe in those moments
yes because he he really hasn't been
like that
like he he's super deceitful actually
so he just um has really just kept
everything to himself and the worst he's
ever done is just stayed up all night
watching tv
and he's never it's never been violent
or anything like that or i would have
left a long time ago
okay i want you to make sure you've got
somebody that you can reach out to that
you can be safe with
the journey for him is going to be hard
and here's why i'm less concerned with
the cocaine i'm more concerned with
the childhood trauma that he's going to
have to stare down
and to heal all the way across the board
he's going to have to
walk that back and he's going to have to
walk that back with a professional you
can't do that by herself
okay and so at some point
it's gonna take the humility and the
character
and the desire to not feel like this
anymore the word i've heard over and
over with folks who struggle with
cocaine is i just got exhausted
i just couldn't like my soul was was
cleaned out right
and so um if he hit send
then i want you to to um then tonight's
the night
tomorrow's the morning right
the old um the old the old it's a
it's an old meditation saying but every
breath is a chance to start over
you don't wait till monday you don't
wait till next month when we figure out
if somebody's ready to go then you go
okay
okay okay um
i want you tonight to write him a letter
so he can have something in his hands
and i want that letter
i want you to let him know how much you
love him do you love him
yes okay i want you to be honest about
the deception
okay and i'm not i'm not beating him up
over cocaine i'm i'm beating him up over
don't lie to your wife not the one woman
who loves you okay
right and let him know that you're gonna
be there
but let him know that you love him so
much you want him to get well
right okay um and then you are going to
need someone to walk alongside you too
because when this thing peels off
there's going to be a lot a lot a lot a
lot of layers
okay yeah you're gonna go through some
seasons of being pissed off at yourself
for missing it you're gonna be pissed
off at him for lying to you the way he
has
you're gonna be upset at the way people
treated him when he was a kid
you're gonna deal with your own trauma
which i know is there and y'all are
gonna have to
completely start over and build a new
marriage together
okay and that could be exciting and fun
if you have that kind of heart about it
and it can be devastating and scary if
you're trying to recreate
that guy that just came in you know the
the the shining armor
on the horseback right that saved
everything for you a few years ago
um you all have to build something new
and you're gonna have to get new skills
to learn how to do that
okay yes i'll also tell you this
you don't have the money for this but
you have to do it okay
yes right that might mean that you're
gonna take a second job
that might mean that he's gonna have to
break down and call his employer and go
through the
um employee assistance program he's
gonna have to reach out to a local
church he's gonna have to get some help
from somebody
i don't know how that financially works
for you you can't not do this
okay okay okay for
and um i just want to tell you i'm
grateful that you love your husband
okay i'm grateful that you love him and
you are lucky lucky lucky that you're in
a safe situation
and um your job is to make sure those
babies
are safe too okay okay all right okay
i'm proud of you um anybody listening to
this
not for a second am i trying to condone
being a cocaine addict not for a second
am i trying to condone being an
alcoholic
not condoning any number of things okay
but until you have sat across from
someone who says i'm done i'm enough
enough then you don't know how
hard drug use is a connection issue man
and if you can look around for the last
40 50 years in this country we went to
war and we lost
because we tried to weaponize connection
we tried to weaponize the one thing that
people were dying from
which is a lack of relationship or
hurting relationships broken
relationships all over the place trauma
and what did we do we we separated them
further from other people we
we we disconnected them even further
now i'm not saying she shouldn't be safe
you heard me say she's got to be safe
man
and sometimes that is i will not be in
relationship with you right now i
love you but you can't stay here i love
you but i'm not
inviting you to christmas i love you
with all of my heart
and i will be there for you i'm not
giving you a penny i'm not going to give
you a dime
but i'll answer the phone when you call
i'm going to send letters
i'm going to make sure you know that
you're loved
and when you're ready he hit send man he
hit send
so when is somebody ready to go to rehab
when they're ready to go to rehab
man i'm gonna be i'm gonna be
thinking about you guys joanna praying
for you to your husband who's watching
this listening to this
i'm proud of you but go go through the
whole program don't quit don't walk out
it's gonna get hard and then it's gonna
get harder
and then after
the hard then it's gonna get ugly
because you're gonna have to stare down
your childhood you're gonna have to
stare down your trauma you're gonna have
to let that little five-year-old boy
that's
been protecting you for so long you're
gonna have to let him
go play you have to let him just go play
and i want you to hold that letter that
joanna's going to write you i want you
to read it over and over and over don't
forget that you're loved you're loved
you're loved
and you got a lot of hard work ahead of
you but you're going to be free of this
thing
and then man the character of the guy
who built the business the character of
the guy who loves his wife
and he's going to tell her the truth
from this point forward he's never going
to lie again
man there's nothing that's going to stop
you
and you're going to be able to help that
guy that you work with you're going to
be able to help that woman that you work
with and you're going to be about
healing your community
instead of taking from it so man
i'm i'm with you guys joanna let me know
how that goes when you drop him off
for his inpatient program i want you to
reach back out to us and let us know how
that conversation goes
and we'll keep the we'll keep our
listeners plugged into this one